to today there was a hearing for the
senate judiciary committee on antifa
violence
and i happened to tune in just around
the beginning because i you know i
worked throughout the day so when i had
the opportunity i pulled the live stream
and i just couldn't do it it was um who
was it senator what's his face oh i
don't remember it it was mazie hirono
and then um i'm ready first name's jeff
i don't remember his last name merkley
yeah is that his name i'm probably
getting his name wrong but he's barkley
you were complaining about him when i
walked in
yeah yeah because he just lied every
it's like it's like i'm watching this
thing
and this guy gets up there and he looks
at the camera and he opens his mouth and
just like
guard like garbage that's pouring out of
his mouth just like human human waste
just like
and he's pouring it all and i'm like
what is this it was all lies
it was all lies and he shows a picture
of like the wall of mom's like and it's
looking all noble with like an upward
angle from the camera and he's like
these peaceful protesters being attacked
by donald trump's
secret unidentified police that's why
i'm introducing this snow
secret police act oh my gosh and i'm
like oh
they're all identified all these guys
have badge numbers yep it's the
stupidest thing ever
and those moms were kicking in the door
house
like for the courthouse yeah the door
house
the door to the courthouse you get it
close enough so here's what i see
take a look at this from barrett wilson
antifa apologist senator mazie hirono
just
walked out of the senate after refusing
to denounce auntie [ __ ] oh yeah ted
i saw this this i i saw clips of it and
ted cruz was like
well it's funny that not one of the
democrats have said anything negative
about antifa at all
hey would you like to say anything who
is it what was their name
maisie hirona would you like to say
anything right now before you leave
and she says something off the mic you
can't hear and he goes something like no
i'm not going to
let it be known she has refused to say
anything negative about antifa and
what she did was this game they play
where she's like of course we denounce
extremism
that's what she said she was like we're
we're not okay with any violence to say
that we won't condemn violent extremism
is wrong
and then ted cruz is like okay will you
say something you know
will you condemn or call out auntie [ __ ]
down she
she won't because these people have gone
insane thinking
they will win the election by supporting
fringe far left extremists who are
burning things down
so i'll tell you what's crazy man
so this george the the george floyd tape
gets released yeah the the body cam
footage
and one of the top posts on reddit that
i ended up seeing was
was the footage the number one comment
was someone saying
this is all wrong like everything this
isn't the narrative that we've exactly
for
three months and they're like all of a
sudden i'm not angry about what happened
anymore the dude was clearly resisting
yeah he kicked his way out he was
fighting with cops
and the guy was like i was getting so
frustrated trying to like screaming at
my phone
dude just shut up and do what they're
telling you to do yeah exactly
now i don't like that idea where it's
like you have to just submit to
these people who have the authority
however there's a thing called strategy
and i think when it comes to the issue
of george floyd and i want to get too
much into this right now because i want
to talk about antifa
but there's a class issue from people
who don't know how you
navigate these scenarios so swallow your
pride
follow the orders and then later if you
were wronged you come back with legal
cases that's how the system works yeah i
mean we talked about it too when when it
first started happening
we were talking about how oh man like
they put him in the car
and then we were told that they took him
out of the car but he didn't he kicked
his way out he jumped out the car
himself he pushes hell to the ground
and his face no no he said hold me on
the ground hold
several times i don't want to get too
much into that i bring that up for one
reason
i have started hearing from people and
i've started seeing the reddit comments
it's really interesting
yeah where they're saying things like i
was already
you know i was completely ready to vote
against trump
and then antifa started rioting and the
far left started rioting
and all the democrats abandoned me yup
wow how insane is it and that's where
i'm at you know sargon makes this video
where it's like tim's on the trump train
with the maga bean and all that stuff
and i'm like okay okay sorry he's a bit
over the top he's confused he's
confusing us
right because you're the maga beanie guy
i think what i will
30k we're at currently we're at 18 000
likes
which is great y'all been smashing that
like button i like it
i'm happy all right at 30 000 likes he
puts the maga beanie on just so you know
so smash the like button i believe
i believe you said the other day 30 000
in super chats
and you'll put the mug at me thirty
thousand dollars i was joking because
i'm not gonna do it
no uh thirty thousand dollars can you
imagine wow
i know that's yours that's crazy yeah
man you could buy a tesla maybe one used
one one day
okay here's the point here's the point
here's where i'm at
i watched them paint black lives matter
murals all over the streets
yeah and i said okay well now i want to
see all the other messages
yep and de blasio said go aft yourself
to all the people who asked for it well
now he's getting sued did you see this
yeah yeah but he already admitted
he violated the law when he went and did
it yeah he used executive authority to
paint the street in front of trump's
building violating the rights of
everybody
who like everybody in the area who
doesn't want that area to become a
spectacle i mean imagine if you run a
business nearby
there's there there is near the trump
the trump tower ace
what is it called waffles and dingus you
know what that is the little like the
little waffle cart food cart yeah little
food yeah i know what you're talking
about now how would you feel
if you had protest after protest ever
protest and you're like
i just wanted to run my business this is
where i'm permitted to have my food cart
and then they painted this without
talking to anybody without getting any
permits from anybody and now there's
protests there's people splashing paint
there's cops everywhere they're fighting
and i can't sell i can't sell a waffle
to save my life
i can't sell a dingus i can't sell any
dingus dingus means toppings for those
who don't know
it's like it's a place but it's more fun
to save without any contact
so the point is this is why we have
permitting processes to make sure
you know we know what's going on but but
the blood doesn't care i see that and
i'm like
this is insane but you know what fine
paint your cellular message i'll leave
your city
then they started releasing people who
had committed crimes
first they started releasing people from
jails and prisons because of kovid and
i'm like well
it's an interesting ethical conundrum
okay i guess and i'm
so i'm still not like we'll see how this
plays out no i don't agree with that
i i think that is absolutely an ethic
conundrum because they
release people from prisons but then put
sick people into
homes okay well that i mean the point
i'm saying is at that time
that's what i think about what was going
on at that time and that pisses me off
when they released the prisoners
there was no discussion about putting
people like people had not died first
they said
there's a concern that people in prisons
will get covered so we need to release
them and i said
i think there is an ethical conundrum
and do you have the right to detain
someone in a situation that could get
them
sick with this this illness in which
case i said okay i guess
then they started arresting business
owners and putting them in the jails
which clearly made no sense
yeah and then i'm like okay now hold on
a minute then cuomo phil murphy and
other governors started putting sick
people in nursing homes and apparently
they're still doing it in some places
in michigan also and people are dying
yeah and i'm like
now hold on there a minute so they're
literally democratics
releasing rioters in dallas fort worth
this is texas man
they said we're dropping the rioting
charges let them go and i'm like whoa
whoa
hold on then the supreme court said no
churches minimal
minimal uh uh people allowed they went
car to car there was a drive-through
procession for churches
they they have taken the constitution
with a smile on their face looked us in
the eye
and taken a big old dump right on it
while we can do nothing but watch
so i'm like you know what i'm not gonna
support them
that's what's changed about what's going
on right now so when i see maisie hirono
when i see merkley or whatever his name
is
and they're lying and they open their
mouths and just human diary like just
diarrhea sprays out all over the cameras
i'm like get these people
out of there i have had enough of this
right now you've got republicans who in
my opinion many of them are just total
garbage but at least they're they're
bending the knee
to the populist wing of the republicans
for now not all of them i do not like
lindsey graham i do not like mitch
mcconnell
there are some there are some younger
republicans who are coming in trump is
certainly not a republican he's a
weird insurgent populist candidate who's
come in and he's
made a bunch of changes that's why they
don't like him at all absolutely and
there's been a bunch of republican
retirements
so i look at the republicans and i'm
like yeah yeah i don't like these guys
but they're not doing a whole lot the
democrats
are whiny babies having a temper tantrum
and when they couldn't get their way
instead of having a reasonable debate
and asking for the support of the
american people
they sicked their attack dogs antifa and
then defended them in court
or i'm sorry in congress that will
literally in court when the ag from from
oregon sues on their behalf and then the
state's like you have no right to sue on
their behalf
i kid you not the a.g sued on behalf of
these far left extremists
and then the judge said you have no
standing to sue on their behalf
and they're like well you know just fine
whatever and stormed out i'm like these
people have lost their minds
clearly ted wheeler went out and joined
them and they were screaming and booing
and i'm telling them to resign he still
he joins them
so i've had enough of this dude it's
really it scares me man these these
people
are absolutely just gonna burn
everything to the ground that's what
they're doing
so i'll tell you what that's why i think
you know what maybe this durham thing
really has something to it
it does for sure i mean they're they all
these people that are in charge
they're probably listed in this report
they're probably the ones that are going
to burn
themselves so who cares about your
country sure yeah figuratively
you know but who cares about the country
if they're going to get arrested and go
to jail for the rest of their lives
why would they care they've got money
they're using every single thing
at their expense to make it happen so so
here's what andy noe said
all right maisie hirono stated numerous
times
at a hearing on antifa today that
they've killed no one in 2019 antifa
militant charles landeros launched an
attack on a school resource officers and
got himself killed
william vance bronson vince bronson
firebombed ice getting himself killed in
both circumstances they tried to kill
people
yep this first guy tried he pulled out a
gun they threw him down and they put a
bullet in his head
so i'm sorry man it it's to me
it's frankly absurd that you're gonna be
like antifa never killed anybody yeah
but not for a lack of trying just
because they're really
bad at what they do doesn't mean they're
not dangerous psychopaths
but he mentions conor betts who posted
tons of pro
antifa stuff all over social media
accounts and then went on a mass
shooting spree killing several people
he killed nine people they mentioned a
bunch of other
points in this post but i'm just going
to show you this the fbi
has opened 300 domestic terror
investigations
as a result of the riots attorney tells
capital uh hearing on antifa
the u.s attorney revealed stats at
antifa hearing chaired by senator ted
cruz
but antifa is not a real thing you know
it's funny
there's a there's a specific antifa cell
that says
here's the date we were founded and if
you want to become a member
it's closed send us an email and we'll
consider you
hmm i thought antibiotic members is that
what i said it's not a real thing
they lied yup so it's like it's it's
they're franchises basically
they have leadership that's a good way
of putting it it is it's a franchise
yeah
so there are leaders there are members
you can join and they cooperate with
each other like a franchise does
and then and then the democrats are the
ones that are defending it how insane is
it
that we can literally have these
extremists do you see what happened
today
happening the other day in seattle what
some some of these far left you know
black lives matter people tried going to
the seattle police chief's house
and then the suv blocks the road they
get out with guns
and they're like we're just peacefully
assembling and they go peaceably
assemble somewhere else
no and they said you know you're
peaceably assembling
because i got a gun the first the first
thing they said was no peaceably
assembled somewhere else
and then they were like dude we're
peaceful protesters and you pointed a
gun at us
and she goes that's why you're peaceful
and i was like
man i'll tell you what freedom of speech
doesn't mean freedom from consequence
and what these leftists like to say all
the time is
the first amendment protects you from
government intrusion
it when somebody cancels you it's them
showing you the door and saying there's
the way out
so let me make it clear for everybody
the government didn't show up
and kick these people out and say you
can't protest it was just
people because freedom of speech means
freedom doesn't mean freedom from
consequence right
so if you want to engage in violent
riots around the country for almost
three months and then when you try
showing up to a residential neighborhood
they come out and jump out with rifles
you can't go it's not fair help i'm
being oppressed no i'm sorry
they didn't work for the government
these are just regular people telling
you they are tired of your bs
and showing you the door called that
months ago yep well
i look forward to people protecting
their communities
you know not not taking this lying down
now
the the important thing in all of this
first and foremost
is peace in the literal version
non-violence like the last thing anybody
i'll tell you what man
to all the people and i've seen people
laugh about like i'd love to
i'd love to see what happens if they
came to my place oh i'll show them what
four it's like bro you don't want
violence man
you know you don't get it these there's
a lot of people who are tough guys on
the left and on the right
um you know i say i say in that way
because the right isn't the one going
out
constantly looking for fights it's
antifa they think they're tough guys yes
they do so but in reality there are you
know
you know tough guys on the right too you
know what happens
as almost every time unless you're
you're a a
psychopathic murderer i've seen these
people man you think you're all tough
until you actually hurt somebody and
then they're like panicking
and they're they're heart palpitations
and they're sweating bullets and they're
begging like man i wish this didn't
happen there i've seen a lot of
you know there have been experiences
going on south side of chicago where
people want to talk big until they
realize what it really means to hurt
somebody and how that affects you how
that affects your life
and you do not want this man you do not
want violence
what we want is the tradition of
you know you know we almost even have
like a revolution every two to
two and four years when we swap out
politicians and have new you know
government officials come in with new
negotiations it's actually pretty
incredible that we can maintain this
that's really what we want we've got a
problem right now with these far left
intersectionalists it's an overt white
supremacist ideology
they just have guilty consciences and i
kid you not sargon brought this up
the robin d'angelo woman straight up
says she is a racist they all do
yeah like these progressives will tell
you they're racists like wow
they're admitting it and marxists yeah
they're they're overtly racist they say
they are
they literally will tell you that and
it's like then why would you take their
advice
when they say repeal civil rights law
that's the craziest thing to me
so this whatever this fringe ideology is
that wants to rewind the clock
this reactionary ideology that wants to
bring us back in time to the 1950s
these people are insane literally so we
need to stop it and we stop it
in the best way possible by standing up
speaking out
you know resistance
quitting your job if you have to like
that woman from msnbc
to be you know and to be just to make
sure it's clear she's talking about all
media
all of it all these big media networks
including fox news she she posted a
follow-up saying
you know fox news published this
clickbait thing about her working for
msnbc and she's like it's all the same
they couldn't they couldn't help
themselves so this is what you do you
you be brave
like uh i'll tell you what you can do
and i mean this
a lot of people have asked me what can
we do let me stress
one important point and then and i'll
tell you what you can do
a lot of people want to know how to
fight back and a lot of people start
talking about riots and protests that
does not
uh riots riots don't work violence don't
and we and we're learning this now
because
trump is doing better in the polls
following all the rioting people are
freaking out and getting angry and
they're asking for help
that's entirely predictable opposition
to black lives matter skyrocketing
clearly showing that the stupidest thing
you can do is engage in violence
it really is and i'll tell you what else
you can do you can go to project veritas
and you can send an email to james
o'keefe and you can
expose these companies that are doing
wrong you can you can talk to him
and you can you can blow the whistle you
can do you know within within whatever
legal channels
you know keeping everything clean
peaceful and legal you can expose this
and that's how our system works because
this country is full of people who love
love this country they're rational
reasonable and they want to live in
peace
so if you come out let's say you work
for one of these big companies and you
know they're doing wrong
like this woman who worked for msnbc man
she's she's like tripled her followers
she's got everybody hitting her up
everyone's writing about her she'll
probably
there's probably going to be like some
new startup that's going to let her
write the journalism she wanted to write
now because she
spoke up about it i hope so that's what
we need so imagine you work for any one
of these companies and you get some
document and you know that they're about
to do something that is a violation of
ethics
you can go talk to project veritas and
you know that they'll publish your story
and they'll and they'll
give you the platform to speak and
expose this and they've also run
run gofundmes for their whistleblowers
yep and they've even hired some of them
so i can't guarantee anything man but
you got to be brave and that's what they
say
i love how they try to attack project
veritas over and over again
they did this hearing on um you know big
tech and censorship
and the journalists all say without
evidence there's no evidence right wing
conspiracy theories
you literally have whistleblowers
publishing documents and video from
inside these companies
and with project veritas being like yeah
actually i worked there
i said this happened here's a video of
it happening and here are the emails
where they ask for it to happen
yeah and the journalist goes hmm like i
said no evidence
so you know what these people are going
to lie but that's what you can do is you
can go out because people are listening
to what veritas is saying
you know we talk about this stuff
be brave and call it out and slam the
insanity
otherwise you're going to end up like at
some point what's going on in louisville
with these black lives matter groups
going to the businesses and saying
you know give us money or else yeah and
then smashing a potted plant
i know so mafioso so something that i i
dawned on me the other day that i had
that i stressed out to the to the world
even if if you don't want to get into
politics that's okay you know
because it takes a lot to fully
understand the whole political realm
but it is imperative that you know who
your representatives are
so look at your mayor look at your state
representatives look at who your
congressmen are look at who they are so
you know who represents you where you're
living
if you don't know who they are that's an
issue and you should go find that out
you should
find out who's representing you and
who's who's trying to run
and then maybe pitch in a few bucks to
that that person that you think should
be and talk to talk to your friends talk
to
other people like a political
conversation needs to be brought back
into the
the norm we we should be talking about
who's our leaders
who's actually leading us so you know if
you don't if you don't want to
get super political i get it but at some
point
you got to be an adult and part of being
an adult in this country
is understanding who represents you and
who's making laws for you
here here we have adam giving this
impassioned speech about
knowing who represents you and standing
up for what you believe in being
responsible mature
and the chat's all like we only need
four thousand more likes for the maga
beanie
they're still going at it yeah they're
popping themselves up down
that's cool i see a lot of people
agreeing with me right now yeah
absolutely
definitely because that's what needs to
happen so one of the things i was going
to pitch in was that my mom used to help
her on the caucuses in the state that we
lived in which i thought was like weird
and uninteresting at the time
but now as i've gotten older i'm like
wow she was like really involved in the
local politics and she knew a lot of our
local leaders and
we would have meals with them and stuff
and it was really interesting so it's
like
maybe you can get involved that way and
help host some of the meetings that
happen in your state
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you